I read the first 50 pages of your book
damn that's pretty good thank you I
thought I I figured it's a hell of a lot
better than Bert Kreischer he didn't
read page one oh man
yeah I bet if you'd have written it on
the inside of a 12-pack he'd have read
it that he would have yeah he would have
oh he's gonna read his own Epitaph soon
dude
wow that's talking about premonitions
that got a little dark a little cold
sorry Bert I want you to be alive you
guys like Bert and you and Tom I'm sure
there's others but those are the main
three that I watched like
you don't have you don't have to pitch
anything you can just make your own
and hundreds of thousands of people or
millions of people are gonna watch it
and you get to do your own like Bert's
got a whole Enterprise over there he's
got movies going and oh yeah he's got a
family cooking me and David Spade just
wrote a movie together who is Mike Hall
one of my childhood Heroes that's
amazing yeah yeah and you didn't need to
go into Sony and like pitch it or
anything like you just kind of did it
yeah Burgess did a movie too yeah he
just did a movie about the machine about
being the machine yeah it's funny
because I just did Bert Bert's podcast
and uh his is a lot bigger than yours
like in what studio size
no like numbers like he's his is huge oh
you're making that up I'm just trying
I'm just trying to sorry sorry I was
trying to incite something but you were
and you are a little man you are and I
like it yeah I was getting it I like it
I have no idea that hurt I just know
that you guys are very very popular but
it was so great because Bert it was so
refreshing because he's like oh you
wrote a book on spirituality that's so
cool
um what do you talk about I'm like oh I
talk about God and he's like I love God
God is awesome I totally believe in God
I love God you know and he's like and it
was like it was
it was so cool to hear that from like a
top comedy guy who was just able to just
say
you know it's a different it's a
different time right now and I think
because things aren't working out so
well and we see big problems and people
are turning and and this is what soul
boom is about
I want it up on that
shelf one of these days you know what
I'll put it up I'll actually you know
what I'll put it in front of This Book
for a while you put it in front of
Jordan Peterson yeah I'd be glad to oh
thank you I really I really uh enjoyed
the 50 pages that I read all right yeah
I hope you read the next 50. I think
there's a lot of things we talk about it
in here
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one